he's a Content K do you know the true
Jordan you're going to decide that are
you what the [__] is wrong with it you
know how they play I want toie
[Applause]
out welcome back to the true Jordie
podcast today's guest is Mom's Taylor
also known as The Man Behind Misfits The
Man Behind a lot of things actually when
you start looking into it um when I
started looking into the history of how
you became Mr Misfits I'm going to call
it um there's a lot that went into this
journey for you it's actually quite
amazing like the first thing that popped
up and I hope you don't mind me bringing
this up was it was so ironic and I'm
sure you know where I'm going with this
was the fact that you dropped Jesse meta
outside of a [__] La night club and
I'm like what did the Garder from
Desperate Housewives ever do to you but
yeah like let's start with that bro like
that was insane that went viral TMZ a
lot well this is the thing right when
you're in that moment and it's fight or
flight and you you forget you don't
think oh that look at all this Paparazzi
here and back then it was a new thing
that everyone had camera phones and
stuff like that it was very new so
growing up in in London basically you
settle your differences like men uh now
you can't do that cuz it's lawsuit it's
a knife it's acid being poured and this
and that so it was quite a normal thing
but going to LA in the Hollywood scene
uh it was more like let me ad him let me
at him and so everyone was appalled that
I threw this punch they're like you're
disgusting how can you do I'm like the
guy just calling calling me out saying
come on you [__] this and that let's
go let's go that must be the prettiest
man you've ever hit by the way he is a
handsome [__] I did I didn't
feel bad I didn't feel bad um he
honestly was very arrogant deserved it
he see the TMZ thing not because it was
a malicious edit you were one of the
first memes by the way like they
literally were rolling this at every
opportunity and any video that they put
out it was crazy because out of nowhere
TMZ's following me every day um hey Ms
do you want to fight Suge Knight I'm
like what you know Ms this that I did
reckon myself and I was a bit of a bad
boy and I'm very lucky that I didn't
come across someone um
someone Less Pretty than Jesse mov in my
journey second thought and isn't it
ironic like you kind of have made a
living as well as a lot of things off of
celebrity fighting when you were one of
the original celebrity fighters in that
moment we were talking about a celebrity
boxing match everyone TMZ was saying
let's run it let's do it unreal yeah so
it is ironic but to just put it out
there also he he really did start it and
he was rude and this and that and they
cut what happened previous to that which
I put him in a choke a re naked and let
him go and then he goes it's on
[__] it's on and then I threw
the punch and then him and four of his
mates jumped me in the club in the
gifting Suite so I had my hands I was
holding a mobile phone I was holding a
gifting uh basket for my girl at the
time and then someone comes and chokes
me and then there's a massive guy and a
really small guy and I'm short I'm 5'7
this guy was like half my height and he
was punching me in the balls it was all
so surreal [__] hell yeah yeah and
this other big guy um they made out with
my shoe nothing bad happened and then
Jesse and I uh made up over time cuz
you're going to run into each other over
and over again and I said let's let's
iron this out and he goes bro no you
know like let's just let's just call it
quits you [__] my career up I'm like
I'm sorry blah blah blah it was just a
Hollywood night that got captured on
tape and you were very much in the
Hollywood scene when I was looking at
the names of people that you've been
working with there's like Good Charlotte
you did stuff with them there's a a
music video with Rampage Jackson and M
launis in it which is your music video
then you've got Snoop Dog the Game Lil
Kim Tain that's like who's who of the
hip-hop era like of that generation what
was that like again I think it was just
I was riding High I was a fixture in the
club scene I owned a nightclub I
co-owned a nightclub and a very hip sort
of sushi restaurant and I think my
existence at the time was very shallow
in terms of I became very successful at
a young age I get to this place where
I'm rubbing elbows with these guys and
it was the norm but um the reality of it
was I didn't really make solid
friendships with any of them not to say
they're all bad people they're not there
some good some bad but it was La is a
hub if you're not careful uh and you
don't know yourself and enough La is a
hub where people will literally step
over their own grandmother to make it
and it's a clout thing but clout back
then was a different thing it was
pre-social media you know but it it's
London is like that these days I think
most big cities are like that now
because more people can be famous
Instagram famous and social media famous
and the irony is the reason I got into
music to be very very honest was because
I remember we were hanging out with um
Timberlake I've known him for a long
time and a few other people and I was
like and I had all this dough and I was
in my 20s I was 25 years old walking
around and I was getting respect and
then I saw Timberlake get a different
level of respect and I saw different
celebrities and athletes and I was like
well [__] this I want to get that
respect so I was good at poetry so I
said let me rap I think I could rap it
was not a great idea but I literally
started getting into music music because
I wanted to be famous and the irony of
it was by the time I got any good at
understanding music and becoming really
passionate about it I didn't want to be
I was like that's the worst thing in the
world to be famous and to be all of that
so it's kind of a spiritual journey that
evolved from getting into something for
the wrong reasons and staying with it
for the right reasons you know isn't not
funny that when you finally honed your
skills and then became as executive
producer for ksr and other artists
you're now in the background and you
don't want the fame really no no and and
you want to be it's it's it's it's kind
of a weird thing because at the end of
the day right let's be honest um and I
love ksi's fans right but the reason you
want to be famous for anything is a
because you want to be acknowledged for
the work you do that's that's a nice
valid side of the validation if you do
good work you want people to respect it
but on the other hand for a young guy
you're just like the validation is like
it comes with women you know for for a
man that's basically what part of the
goal is why do we do half the things we
do maybe 80% of the things we do right
especially when you're a youngster so
and if you don't have an identity that
you're sure of yourself you gravitate
towards these things that you think oh
this image of me is going to be cool
rather than understanding who you really
are and being embraced for that and what
we take for granted is we underestimate
how intelligent other people are people
see through our [__] when we put an act
on but you don't think that you think oh
they'll think of me like this yeah did
you look back at it and feel like people
seeing you for what you were and maybe
you found a lot more substance later on
in life and discovering who you really
are the more you know yourself the less
you give a [__] what anyone thinks yeah
and that's a journey you know I feel
sorry for these kids on Insta my
daughter's 19 years old and I love her
more than anything but I always feel bad
because she's a beautiful super talented
girl but her all of her friends everyone
they're all constantly being force-fed
all these images of these girls who are
uh you know showing themselves on
Instagram to look a certain way and I've
been on dates with some of these girls
they don't look the same in real life
you know but that pressure is always on
and you're always comparing yourself to
those people so it's it's a really
slippery slope and I think you know I
think limiting the amount of time you
spend on that is really really important
for for a kid we've got an unlimited
access to be famous like everyone and
anyone can be famous and that's great
because we're we're unearthing gems left
right in center like KSI for example who
maybe if it was still just limited to
what the mainstream media would allow
into the club would not have made it but
kind of it's opened the floodgates for a
desperate Chase for fame for people who
are going going to waste their lives
trying to get famous it's going to
happen a lot of the and you're going to
say it more than anyone because you're
essentially a king maker now in this
space you can go I'm going to take you
and I'm going to bring you onto the
record label I'm going to take you and
I'm going to bring you on to Misfits
that comes with responsibility and
itself because some people mentally
aren't fit for that a lot of people
aren't and I think that I'm not a trying
to be a preachy person but I think
having some spiritual grounding and when
I say spiritual I you know it can be in
any form it's spirituality a lot of it
is actually just being present and if
you're really present you're capable of
understanding and appreciating and
walking with gratitude honestly for me
it's very hard for me to ever be
depressed even when I've lost everything
even when I've gone through massive
battles because I've always remained
grateful optimistic and disciplined and
when you have a routine and you're
disciplined I've I've had I've had
depression come to me at times and um or
it comes from within I guess or
experiences traumas all that but for me
having a routine that I'm disciplined to
carry out makes it very difficult to
stay still and I think when we're still
and not still in the positive way but
still in the way of we're giving
ourselves so much time to be up here in
our heads then it's that becomes our
enemy what were those challenges like
was there one thing that stands out in
your story pre
this this new version of you that's
really coming into your own clearly
where you were like God that was that
was a real point of who the [__] am I I
had uh tens and tens and tens of
millions in the bank liquid money a
massive mansion in Beverly Hills nine
cars Lambos this that traveling on 180
ft yachts and private jets uh rubbing
elbows with everyone and having uh
dating like the hottest
of the hottest in LA and flying around
doing all this and I was in my room and
I had you know I I had company with me I
was just I woke up and I'm just like and
I was partying and not to go into detail
but I was partying and and I was just
like I've got everything why am I so
[__] lonely why do I feel lonely and
I'm never alone MH and that's why I felt
lonely cuz I was never alone and I was
never comfortable with being alone so at
that point I said this little
affirmation or prayer I said like I said
God please bring let me have happiness
what can I do to have happiness within 6
months I lost close to 70 million bucks
every penny I had gone how did that
happen uh um the market bad bad
Investments uh trading like I was
gambling like I I knew what I was doing
and I didn't I just had this arrogance
because I was on an upswing and I had
all this luck and all this other stuff
kept happening I was a good Hustler but
I wasn't as knowledgeable as I thought I
was at all and yeah I got stung and it
happened over a six-month period very
quickly to the point where I had about20
just under $300 to my name no watches
left no cars no art no house nothing and
it was the most liberating amazing
feeling to have that because I also lost
all the friends the the fake friends I
only had a few good ones now and yeah
your circle gets smaller when the [__]
hits the farm bro massively and there
were a couple of good ones that stuck
through it all you know you know what
sometimes it's the ones you don't expect
as well totally and the ones you truly
believe are going to be there they're
the quickest out the [__] do listen
there's a guy without mentioning names
there was a guy I flew out uh on a
private jet uh loved him he was like I
thought he was great mate of mine uh
would come on the hang out on the boat
and I pay everything the bills this that
the other ended up screwing me hardcore
another guy uh I loaned him 500 Grand
just like it was nothing he's like hey I
can't pay my dad's uh black AMX Bill
he's going to kill me I'm 500 short and
that was part of the circle of people I
was hanging out with those Rich Kids CBS
athletes this that so I was like all
right no problem when I lost everything
I said listen I need to borrow 10 grand
I'm selling my last watch and I'll pay
you back easy cuz the watch is worth
more he just disappeared and I saw this
guy probably 5 days a week the tit it's
a strange thing isn't it cuz you've
created that in a way I did I totally
created it well this is the other thing
I learned is and I'll tell you Brian I
think for me losing money was never um
painful I adapted very quickly to new
sets of circumstances I'll tell you a
quick story I was I was friends with Kim
K good friends right this guy come over
to the house was up was that like what
year are we talking roughly do you know
pre yeah yeah pre yeah she was
relatively famous not as big as Paris
Hill and yes yeah and and she would come
over hang out she'd set me up with mates
and we never had any attraction it was
more just like she was a mate I met her
family lovely really nice in person to
everyone and um she saw me with all
these supercars and she'd like there's
one Bentley I had and she's like can I
borrow this I'm going on day I'm like
yes sure
you know and then she was with the she
was with another fell at charity event
like ma'am so seen her for a while and
this has past the sex tape release and
she's now huge right massive I haven't
seen you for so long she's telling her
boyfriend this guy has the best cars at
this point I had a rented Ford Focus
okay so as the valet is bringing the
Ford Focus around she's coming out and I
get into it proudly I'm like yeah [__]
it and I say bye Kim and she's just
looking like no way why is this boy in a
Ford Focus you know but that stuff that
stuff didn't bother me what bothered
what hurt me was money I can make with
honestly without much effort I can
manifest money into my life what was
really tough for me was relationships
the reason I wanted to make money was
because I thought this is what's going
to validate me and what's going to
validate me is when I I remember being a
kid in school and I was the only Brown
kid in my class it was tough because I
was rejected I had crushes on everyone
my older brother was like Mr Saturday
Night Fever and he was this guy like
John Travolta in the clubs took me to
string fellows when I was 14 Legend yeah
totally so I'm seeing that and and until
I was about 15 years old I had no luck
with women at all and I was terrible at
it I just I kept getting rejected and
I'd go up to girls that I didn't know
and I'd be like look I really love you
I've I've made this mixtape for you
[__] cringing and embarrassing right
looking back when I was a kid I think I
got the money cuz I thought that's what
validates me and makes me attractive
because I didn't know who I am and what
I have to offer beyond that so then
going so hard and making money my God at
the time um was was the mistake and then
obviously you're going to lead to
relationships and I'm going to what
happens is you tend to attract people
make you feel familiar to the feelings
you had as a child growing up so true
I've got friends of mine whove had bad
relationships with their mothers and
they replicate that with their misses of
course weird yeah unless it heals you
can heal it yeah you can and awareness
is the first step but it's not the only
step as I found out three wives later
you know so that's good numbers bro yeah
so I was totally unaware I just thought
and I thought it's all their fault and
I'm the Savior I'm coming to save them
and I see them troubled and this and
that and you've got the money to save
them and it wasn't that though it was I
would do anything to avoid looking in
the mirror and saving me from what I
really have to overcome because that's
much harder than saving someone else
which you can't do you try and save them
you you give them a little bit of a
honeymoon period soon after that you're
both back to what you were going into
the relationship but now you've got a
scapegoat now you look at each other and
say it's your fault that I'm miserable
because you have someone else there to
avoid your own feelings and your own
demons and that kind of thing so I
learned that the hard way and realized
actually if it's 90% your fault 90%
their fault in your mind in your logical
men's mind and I'd be like okay this is
what I'm going to do I'm going to take
that 10% and I'm going to take
responsibility for that 10% and don't
focus on the other that's where magic
really [__] happens because the
moment you say hey look I'm sorry I did
this the other person as a human being
90% of the time will go you know what
I'm sorry I did that now you're not
challenging each other's egos it's when
you challenge each other's egos that it
just goes and erupts into a vicious
circle you're so right and and relenting
that power and just stopping the fight
and and giving yourself to each other
and going I'm 100% here for you you're
100% here for me and we're on the same
team instead of two opposing players
almost you know what I mean challenging
each other to be leader of of the pack
um and going back to what you were
saying about the money as well if
obviously if you're I'm assuming if
money is your god like you were saying
you're also attracting women who AR with
you for you they don't know why they're
there with you they justify it to
themselves that it's a good reason
people think but at the same time I'm
attracting someone because I think
that's a status symbol for me to be
dating this celeb so why is that any
better than them dating me because of
money it's both shallow shallow premise
to build on to be honest with you yeah
you know this relationship I'm in now
for example it's built on proper proper
friendship respect there's not one
single fight all we do is laugh joke and
and just and and it's happened very
organically there's no there's no agenda
there other than you you have to grow up
to get to that point though don't you
[__] hell do you and it's a lot of
suffering to get there a lot I feel like
I'm in the same place right now in my
head in my my life you have to grow to
get to that point where you're like okay
here's my selfworth here's who I am I
know what I am I know what I want and I
know what I'm looking for and
unfortunately you do have to be humbled
a lot to get to that point and I think
you look looking at what you've been
through I've been through a similar
thing where I've lost things on the day
you do it it's hard but like you say it
is liberating because you do find out
who the [__] is real and who isn't and
you do build a much better friendship
group out of that and you do realize who
you really are and that money isn't who
you really are it is just a thing that
helps you live a certain way rather than
being the goal and yeah what was Kim
Kardashian like by I just going by like
was there other celebrities of that ilk
that you were hanging around with like
what drop some names come on no there
were a lot we were all we were all
hanging out uh a lot at the time a lot
of the athletes a lot of there was a
club Bri called Teddy's and it was run
by this uh amazing woman called Amanda
Demi I remember pulling up I was in a
three-piece pinstripe suit Tony Montana
style my hero right so I pull up uh in a
Carrera GT like this this the first one
out there is like you know and back then
500 grand for a car was a lot of money
you know my boy had an Enzo behind we go
in she goes you're not coming into this
club you guys are cheesy as [__] you
this isn't what I want and I was like
what do you mean and she goes I said
well get us 20 bottles of Chris let's go
and she goes no that's not how it works
here it was the first place in La that
had ever been like that she said but I
like your energy I can tell you're a
nice guy you're a bit lost but just come
back on come back tomorrow and we'll
have a chat came back she bought me five
beers and we just she said sit down I'm
get I'm buying the rounds of beers for
you guys this that that Club pre TMZ
pre- camera phones and you had Jack
Nicholson doing his thing on the table
you had um what's the girl's name
Jessica Simpson to um I I don't know
Jessica Alba you had a-listers all over
the shop and no one was worried and they
were all doing what they're doing not
worried about it you know and it was it
was a it was like Jack's legendary
reputation yeah yeah yeah it was like
Studio 54 of the modern era and it only
lasted for about 9 months before uh the
camera phones and the TMZ stuff you
invested into lady garg's career before
anyone before before she was even lady
gargo yeah cuz I remember seeing her on
MTV shows like you know there's there
there's clips of her before she became
famous where she was like doing her
thing so did you spot her Talent before
it all took off no um someone brought
her to me and said like she's going to
be massive sign to into scope let's
let's do this thing together that kind
of thing when she became massive what
happened was I was like oh [__] I have
no money left where else where else have
I invested and where else oh yeah well
lady gogas obviously I've and it's not
like I just left it uh for years I had a
relationship did you start working with
her in the studio yes so I I was in
studios with all these guys some some of
you know from T Snoop to uh Robbie uh
all these guys just sitting there try
but I had no clue what I was doing so I
wasn't getting credit for anything that
I was doing I wasn't registering my
publishing I went to the School of Hard
Knocks and basically got done left left
right and center but got an education
out of it and realized and had to learn
the hard way I didn't go in there as a
musical guy because honestly my mom
still listens to Julio glacius and um
and maybe a bit of Bon Joi at most you
know so I didn't have a diverse musical
background I didn't learn the flute I
didn't do any of that but it was just I
into this and I'm morphed into this area
because my passion before that was was
theater just acting I didn't want to do
film I just loved acting on stage but I
got sick and tired of getting cast as
either a terrorist or or a Mexican
gangster and I could do the voes well I
did them but so then I got a job on the
door and I was working in the West End
for a few years did really well uh
relatively speaking from that and uh did
well for the club and then made a lot of
relationships and got into real estate
and all this other stuff and wow this
makes sense now when you say you immerse
yourself in the studio realm are you
learning how to make beats are you
writing or all of the above all of the
above and I just I basically faked it I
just I I would act like I know what I'm
doing and I'm sure if there was a
compilation of clips of stupid things
I've said and done to the big
celebrities and people
the cringe would be unbelievable you
know I would probably melt but yeah I
it's just all stuff I learned but also
was the fact that I was in these clubs
having a convoy of six cars follow each
other all the beautiful women uh big uh
bouncers I was I was so cringe at one
point but I knew it I was aware of this
I had two gisha girls dressed in full
Gaye outfits Fanning me at the club
wherever I went people was oh my God
that guy what what is he doing but as
soon as you give them attention in La
they'd be like okay yeah I'll come hang
out you know yeah so it worked then it
did work at the time and it's all based
on that like that insecurity of you
being that that short kid you know who
felt like he was neglected from women
and it was all of that I had this I had
this Alpha Male inside me but my
perception of an alpha male it was wrong
basically it was off an alpha male is
James Bond he's cool he doesn't give a
[__] he doesn't get upset about little
things you know someone who's um maybe I
don't know if that's a good example no
no I hear you but you know your
insecurity was pouring out my insecurity
was crazy and it was a cultural thing as
well bringing that in and being the only
kid you know I I wasn't allowed to speak
English uh we didn't speak English in my
house until I was like four five years
old so I'd go to nursery and I didn't
know what the [__] anyone was saying I
was so frustrated hard yeah I think I
learned early on overcoming challenges
is is an appealing thing to me and
whether it was a girl and things back
then were very different to what they
are now when when a girl said hey I'm
not interested in you uh uh you're short
you're not my type and I'm uh dating
George Clooney currently so [__] off um
that wasn't a no to me that was like
okay you're going to wake up with 500
roses shoes in your size I've spoken to
your publicist this that and an
invitation to dinner and this and that
and then she became my wife you know so
really yeah so it was a different it was
well that really happened you [__]
mad bastard yeah and more like things
like that all the time wow this just so
much I'm getting hit with right there
with
let's go on the woman thing cuz the one
thing that did make me gig a little bit
and I hope you don't mind me saying this
go go but there's an iconic moment in
movie history yeah in Liar Liar yes and
I could not believe this because I've
seen this clip a thousand times and if
anyone has it's when Jim KY gets in the
elevator and he looks next to a woman he
can only tell the truth and he says
you've got massive jugs right and she's
a very pretty woman you married that
woman yeah that that alone gave me an
Insight of like oh this man wants the
the the thing that every man is wanting
you and for whatever reason I don't know
what that woman was like obviously I'm
sure she was lovely and that's your
business but you were looking for status
you were you were finding women who
added to your value for sure 100% and
look she's an amazing woman who's
overcome a lot for herself as well m
can't say a bad word but together we
were oil and water just like anyone I
was attracting so it's like when you're
attracting these uh it's not it's not
that you're better than them right it's
it's that you're both completely
clueless to the ability of taking
responsibility for who you are and you
know how people are like love yourself
first before you love anyone if you
wholly loved yourself then you wouldn't
have any time to love anyone because
it's it's a [__] work in progress
Journey that losts 1502 years beyond our
lifetimes but if you're able to be
self-aware enough to acknowledge the
baggage you come with and don't ask the
other person to hold that baggage
there's some things that inevitably
you're going to take on together if you
fall in love and everything else but but
being conscious of
not making the other person responsible
for your happiness it's such a big big
thing you know um because the truth is
only you can make yourself happy only
you can and perspective has a lot to do
with that and we get comfortable in
these situations um where we we rely on
other things we rely on money and and
cars and things that stuff doesn't make
you happy I say that from experience
having been broke having been wealthy
and having made it back again uh and
from a very different standpoint I'm not
at the club anymore going back into this
this lady gaggar situation you're in
this lawsuit so you invested money into
her her and you didn't have anything to
to show for the situation that you'd
help build I guess yeah and we settled
after a few years of basically me um you
know living living paycheck to paycheck
and everything else and that that helped
me get back on my feet did that create a
a rift in terms of emotionally between
you and her and maybe other artists that
you've worked with before when that's
gone sour no um I mean I was never super
close with her or anything like that you
know I met her the first time I met her
she came to my house in a tracksuit and
hair in a bun and I was just like wow
she's really talented and she's very
confident and different and I
immediately said she I said to uh my
friend that introduced us I said she's
definitely a star 100% let's get behind
it let's do it let's figure it out and
I'll say
this I think that me losing all of that
money and then getting a settlement I
got what I deserved in in terms of I
think on the come up I wasn't I wasn't
the person I am now I didn't have the
same set of principles I would be like
ju I justify taking more money I was a
bit of a scumbag with that because I
didn't know I didn't have the moral
compass and I said oh well I did way
more work than this guy even though we
said let's go 50/50 I'm going to take
900 and you get 100 Grand and I paid for
it and it all got taken from me
basically that's my philosophy of it I
think it's almost a
self-imposed um karmic sort of
Retribution and this makes a lot of
sense because look obviously we're we're
kind of work together a little bit I'm
behind the scenes on Misfit and I see
how you treat the fighters very
fairly and I can only assume that all of
those experiences have played into why
you are the way you are now 100% you
know how some people are naturally just
nice people with a great moral compass
they make the right decisions they know
the difference between right and wrong I
don't think I had that luxury so it was
a Voyage of Discovery and things
wouldn't feel good like sometimes doing
something bad would would end up hurting
you you know like cheating on on someone
you were with or whatever that kind of
stuff ended up hurting me and I thought
oh I'm Jack the Lad it's okay to have a
wife that you love as long as you treat
her well and as a man you should be able
to do whatever you want but she hasn't
consented to that you haven't we haven't
had that Arrangement there's no honesty
and I'll tell you what putting my phone
out and not taking it to the shower with
me feels really good man you know we can
both agree on that as well bro we got
definitely learned a lot over the years
cuz uh cheating when you first start
doing it as a as a Young Man sometimes
you justify in your head of oh I haven't
been treated well so therefore [__] this
and I'm going to go and do what I want
in this moment and and look sometimes I
I get why men we do that right and
sometimes that's a sign right there bro
you know if you're feeling that way then
obviously you shouldn't [__] be there
but for whatever reason sometimes we
don't make that decision and we keep
going and uh and now as a as a as an
older guy I feel it's so nice to have a
clean conscience and not feel wrecked
with guilt and hiding and lying is so
taxing a lying is so much energy like
the the the best life you can live is
one without lying for sure it's so much
more clean it feels like eating clean it
honestly feels the same when you when
you when you put your head on your
pillow and you know you've done your
best you know to be a good person and to
to try to live by a certain code and I
think that weight that you carry of that
guilt some people are really good at it
and they don't they don't feel the guilt
as much I guess I mean that they're
basically psychopath in my opinion yeah
but I I agree like to be able to do [__]
like that is a skill in itself and not a
good one and going back to the KSI thing
so you you you've obviously you've left
the lady gargar situation you've set up
your own management company and you're
introduced to JJ what were you making of
him at that point and and what how long
ago was this roughly
2008 right so he'd been dabbling in
music a bit but obviously nothing had
quite taken off anywhere near the level
of what it did once you got involved and
when were you like yeah I can I can make
this happen for you SX called me he's
like hey I'm doing I'm I'm doing some
work with KSI and and uh I was like oh
that's the guy who did the boxing match
I think it with I think he' done Logan
yeah that would have been Logan yeah and
Joe Weller so I said okay okay yeah my
daughter showed me that match and this
and that I was like cool and he goes bro
he's really really a good guy he's a
great guy and I think we could you know
help him out with music and he doesn't
his he doesn't really have a manager
who's helping him with music that
understands music I said okay let's set
up a call I think it was the next day or
whatever I did my research on him
listened to his songs and then uh we got
we we got on a call spoke for about 30
40 minutes and by that point I believed
and I saw the vision I was like he's got
a unique voice he's got a fan base
having a fan base on a different
platform can be a massive disadvantage
to having a music career you know many
many many people have tried and failed
so as much as people think oh well
you've got a base already uh most of his
fans wouldn't really really they didn't
take they didn't love his music as much
they wouldn't show up show up to his
music uh but they'd show up for a meet
and greet for example right so these
were things I looked at and I just I
said to him I said if you're really
dedicated um these are the goals we're
going to we're going to get your a top
10 in the UK we're going to get a number
one album we're going to get a number
one single and then we're going to break
America he goes all right let's just
start and he was just chill he's like
he's like that sounds good I'm excited
but at the end of the and and that was
it he signed the contract like 5 minutes
later after one call and I was like you
sure and he goes yeah man I I got good
feeling and I said me too and we built a
relationship that was based on trust it
was I think we built the trust I mean we
got tested a lot and I think I think the
Loyalty was a big big thing how do we
get tested a lot of people saw me
rushing and they saw me as an outsider
and some still do the thing with me is
that I've been with all of my clients we
have even even the kids that work for me
uh Jake ABS these guys who run uh UK and
us and all that for the music side of
things we have a moral code and we have
a a sort of monik where we say the
mental and physical health of our client
comes before everything before every
check before anything that's number one
number two is their brand long-term and
their connection with their fans not
doing something that's going to alienate
your fan base and this and that of
course you can't control their every
move but strategically as a manager and
as a management company you want to be
aligned with that and third Comes the
Money and we've JJ and I have
rejected maybe 300 plus million dollars
since we've started working together
just from all these things that didn't
align with um making him happy the
exertion of energy to put into this
shoot and that you know how is Brian
people think oh he's just doing an ad or
a music video or this and that that
takes a lot mentally and physically I'm
not saying feel sorry for anyone but it
does take energy to do that there's only
so many hours in the day and people
forget that and you get dragged in a
million different directions so it is
important to have someone looking out
for a mega starter like him sure that's
genuinely when you when you see what a
nice guy is you know him of course away
from the KSI image and everything else
the the humility he's a humble guy he's
very helpful to so many people very
quietly some some you know are in the
public eye but some very quietly I've
seen things that he's done um and the
first time was when we had an intern on
the music video to the trippy red KSI
song uh wake up call and this intern
comes and uh and KSI is like hey man I
have no Wi-fi um and I said to the
intern I was like rushing around I was
like hey man give me your phone I need
to use it for JJ to be on your hot spot
and you just got to keep your phone here
JJ was like no no no hold on what's your
name bro uh are you sure it's okay that
I use your phone is it okay with you
like I know you know everyone's glued to
their phone so I don't want to yeah he
he's very polite for sure he'll make
sure he knows everybody's name he's the
first person there to show up and he's
the last to leave he's got the work
ethic and I see what frustrates me that
everyone wants the same results that he
gets without putting in the work mhh and
let's go back to the outsider yes right
because if there's one thing that
everyone who's close to to JJ
understands is is like a lot of people
depend on him and and when you become
the the money bag everyone is your
friend and everyone wants a piece of you
so you're coming in with a legitimate
set of skills that can potentially
Elevate him to another level but other
people don't know that you know and it's
not necessarily even that they're trying
to keep them for their themselves but
you are an outsider at that point so
what kind of difficulties did you come
up against people who shall remain
nameless you know I'm not trying to
start beefs and things but people tried
to [__] block a lot of deals people
tried to [__] block things um what kind
of deals would you like the First music
deal we did we got was that with Sony no
it was with BMG okay uh after they they
wer po pot of Sony at that point got him
a mega deal as an independent artist
stays independent owns his own masters
big check uh freedom to basically do
what we want creatively why did they try
a [__] block that do you think it's not
always
malicious sometimes it might be but I
think that most people's perspectives on
their opinions and advice is sprinkled
with their own objectives as well of
course you can't blame people for that
and uh but at the same time it's very
hard to give a selfless uh very
objective opinion when you're in the mix
in some capacity mhm when you're getting
a cut of the deal or maybe not getting
cut of this deal but would have gotten a
cut of a different deal but the problem
was the different deals were a lot
smaller and a lot less valuable and a
lot less cool and a lot less you know
they so nothing compared to it um like
take Prime for example but look I I did
I was doing well before I met JJ at that
point I was already back on my feet
doing pretty well and then JJ comes
along and as much as I helped uh
facilitate a lot of things for him he
was the perfect partner to do that with
because his work ethic his principles
and I I literally have said no to
working with again names I won't mention
because they're Pricks and I don't want
my energy to be expended on people who
are going to give me a hard time for
nothing you know and be primadonnas and
this and that that guy isn't it's funny
it it kind of reminds me of the story of
Dr Dre when he hit a bit of a lull when
death row had finished and he he he was
people were looking at him like you know
you're
and then he found Eminem and it just
give him a new lease of life and he was
back up you know feeling the best he
could yeah and it sound sounds a bit
like that how he's was a cutless for you
as well 100% I mean I think we brought
out the best in each other we've got
each other's backs and we're honest with
each other and also we're not afraid to
disagree with each other he'll you know
he'll tell you and I'll tell you the
same many times we've buttered heads but
we we cool off tell me one of the one of
the times you remember specifically
where you were like this was biblical
Prime oh really yeah Prime am I right
thinking you're part of the Prime deal
as well yeah yeah so basically I think
this is the biggest one we've had loads
and and sometimes I've been wrong i'
I've not I'm not always right 100% but I
I can walk away and reflect and say a
[__] you know what you were right about
this yeah and I've seen that myself from
like us doing the Misfits chats you are
very open-minded for sure I definitely
tried to you know but but what happened
was um we're in a group chat six
Partners was Logan one of those yes
and I think we were a week away from
launching okay and contracts were about
to be signed something happened in the
group chat where JJ got offended okay
and it wasn't because he was wrong to be
offended and it wasn't because the the
intention was to offend him at the same
time it was a total mismatch
miscommunication American and English
sense of humor not was that Logan or no
I let me let me not say more than that
it actually wasn't but okay um but it
was it was a
misunderstanding and and it was a series
of that happening and I you know as
someone who lives in America I
understood it and I was like oh no this
is going to get taken wrong blah blah
blah so I'm just sort of like feeling
awkward and I was right JJ emailed the
lawyers hey I don't want to do this I'm
out and deleted himself from the group
chat
dude when you think about what prime has
become wow yeah I mean you the the
amount of money like just let's just
estimate what the what is the value
currently of prime what are they valuing
at do you know I'd say it's about 8 to
10 billion okay so it's a it's a mega
company and at that moment you don't
know that but you know there's potential
there and you're watching it walk out
with the WhatsApp group yeah yeah no it
was bad because look the seed was
planted when I I hit Logan up and I said
I want you to be on the KSI show as the
Ghost of Christmas Past or whatever this
this thing we had for the KSI show yeah
yeah remember we had a lot of criticism
for as well but it was a great shot I
enjoyed it still I anyway um Logan was
really cool and I'd been saying to JJ
post their second fight I'm like it's
difficult to not like this guy on
impulsive I'd been watching him all I've
been there when I when I met Logan the
first time and I was like you know UK
guy team Ki and all of that and I
disliked Logan's actions previous to
that but when you meet him people don't
understand he's a nice guy and you know
what won me over going back to the
incident is when I called and called
Logan and I said hey I need to talk to
you um I'm not giving up but right now
as it stands this is what's going on and
the prime thing Logan was a [__]
Superstar about it he was
self-reflective very calm very
understanding and also he was like look
it's it's [__] cuz we've all done so
much work for this you know I mean
especially Logan JJ and the you know the
guys the other guys behind it who are
geniuses they put a lot of time effort
energy into this so the way he reacted
and the way the other guys reacted was
so cool that I then went back to JJ and
I said listen you can't just say no I'm
not doing this as a man this isn't this
isn't something that is right and he
said to me you're right you know he
didn't argue and resist it it was 2 days
after cuz I knew needed a cooling off
period And I said just do me one favor
we have a
call with everyone and you guys chat say
your peace they'll say their peace and
if at the end of that call you say to me
Ms don't want to do it I'll never bring
it up again you know this is the type of
older brother type advice that everyone
needs you know we all have that hote
headed moment in US you do I do as as
men but to just have someone to go just
[__] and that's why I I try not to
make decisions In the Heat of the Moment
if something's happening I give it a
couple of days and then I think about it
you know and I think that's such good
advice it's the best that might have
saved this man billions like we're not
even joking that one conversation is
that domino effect that could have
changed his life even JJ was always
going to be good but this is another
level of wealth that we're talking about
yeah but similarly I I can't remember
he's done exactly the same for me where
I've been hotheaded and he's like bro
and he's I remember Misfits um remember
when Jake went in on us about uh Wasabi
being replaced swarms in his pajamas
that wasn't a nice day for me man and I
did the I went out and did a video and
I'd had a [__] edible
okay and I just said [__] this and I
start doing the squirrel impression oh
[__] and then I was like I wasn't used
to this I realized that this was a
baptism of fire for you actually it was
and I wasn't used to any of this and it
was like fire this guy this and that
people also don't know behind the scenes
what goes on and everything else so
everyone's like fire him fire him who is
this guy why is he giving these guys to
JJ and it was a a plethora of different
circumstances that came together that
forced certain events to happen and I
take responsibility for my parts in that
but JJ called me and he just goes hey
bro I know you and I know you're going
through it and I know you're very strong
but I know I know what it's like it's
getting to you right now isn't it cuz I
can I can feel it and I'm like bro it is
kind of [__] get to me man this sucks
like I'm not used to to the internet
everyone calling me a 60y old man and
[__] you're this you're that you and
you know what mate when you're throwing
in at the deep end like you are like you
didn't get the training school that a
lot of people get like a lot of people
will grow grow grow they'll have an
interaction with KSI that'll help them
build and they'll go through a few
things you literally are like boom
you're the guy welcome to Misfits but I
also this is the crazy thing I wish
there was a way and don't get me wrong I
love I've never met as much as as much
hate as I get on Twitter for certain
things or whatever from Jake paulers or
what and it's nothing compared to JJ on
in my world of never being used to any
negativity maybe maybe once in a while
when it was on World Star and I was
wearing makeup on the Snoop song you
know I got some I got some comments here
and there but I had to find that funny
anyway but but this was just a barrage
of non-stop I don't remember who said
this to me but someone said if they
don't know you personally don't take it
personally whoever said that is a genius
it's really true it's fact M and and and
you know in that moment like I my first
impression of you wasn't great either
because I'm like who's this guy starting
on Joe well this is mental but the more
we've gotten to know you on and off
camera I think yes you're human and yes
you've made mistakes but like we're
looking at this Misfits Prime card now
as almost like your graduation as a
fight promoter like you've had your topy
and even Eddie Hearn is still having
these moments till this day and he's
been doing this for years he's still has
moments where you think and he's
Immaculate he's he's fantastic he's one
of the best promoters of all time but
even times I look at him and I go [__]
me why would you say that mate so it is
going to happen like all fots are going
to do it the more you're on camera the
more you're on a mic mhone the more
you're susceptible to saying something
stupid at some well yeah you're talking
to the
expert and it happens right and and and
it doesn't I think to ourselves we've
got to make sure we know that it doesn't
Define who we are to ourselves even
though from a from Outsiders looking in
that's how they're going to see it
that's the guy who did this that's the
guy who did that that's that's the way
they look at you but you know my donkeys
don't view me like that my just to be
clear he owns a f yeah that's not a
nickname for anyone no yeah my horses
don't think of me as the guy who did a
squirrel face and [__] hit Jesse meof
they don't give a [__] about that but
the irony of it is again I have a
personality I can't help that I have
that I'm a passionate person the the
irony of it is I'm not out here looking
for followers and clout and this and
that I could give a [__] at this point
in my life definitely not it's not a
thing but yeah when I wanted to be
famous it was the most evasive thing in
the world and I'm not saying I am now
but if I wanted to ironically now you're
not bothered about it it's right there
if I wanted to do like oh let me do a
YouTube channel and do this and do that
I only want to do things that are fun
and I'm passionate about and even those
things come with mental challenges
nonstop why do you think KSI chose you
to run Misfits I think from his first
fight with Logan uh from his second
fight with Logan I was involved in the
music so I got Rick Ross and SX we that
was the first song I did with KSI boss
yeah boss got give it up the big man and
the the ring entrance and all that it
was sick like yeah what a night but but
I remember I wasn't that close to him
I'd met him twice three times we'd
spoken on the phone a bunch of times and
after he won I went into the locker room
talk about being an outsider yeah I went
into the locker room I was like yes yes
JJ I gave him a big hug and he was like
a bit like all right come down and
everyone was looking at me like who's
this guy you know and I was like oh [__]
I was like I'm really excited you won
you know but he wasn't trying to be I
think it took time for JJ to see that
I'm genuine with him and my intentions
are aligned with him I mean and you know
the saddest thing I've thought about
this before and I don't mean this is a
knock on JJ at all it's just like in his
shoes I can only assume you will almost
never know who your true friends are
because you'll never see them tested to
the fullest extent like only when you
have that moment that you had and that
I've had where you have zero in the bank
account and where the people who you've
had built around you for the money you
know have a reason to either stay or go
uh then you'll find out but he'll never
have zero he'll never and as much as he
can get a good idea and he'll think you
know as well as I do until those
[__] are tested you You' be
shocked at how many people will walk
away from you in that scenario there's
been small and medium tests here and
there you know and I think I think he's
become more astute and more aware of of
that energy now and that's because he's
done a lot of work on himself so the
more you do on yourself the more you're
aware of other people because they're a
reflection of either who you are or how
you've been yeah he said he did therapy
and I can only assume you think you've
seen the the results of that amazing
amazing because I remember and again JJ
is such a people pleaser in some ways
you know not all the time but he has
that quality where we would go um we
were going really hard on the music it
was crazy crazy scheduling and this and
that and I would check in on him I'm
like are you okay how are you feeling
and he wouldn't say he wouldn't open up
and say bro this is too much then
suddenly he would blow up and he'd be
like I can't do this you know and I was
like all right we need to reset take a
break let's figure out what we need to
do what do you want you know like we'd
have a lot of these conversations it's
both ways because even when he I'd learn
from him as much as I was a big brother
I'd learn from him from observing how he
treats people and how he is with people
I was like wow this guy is so
spiritually grounded without ever doing
spiritual work um outside of therapy and
stuff but I've been to freaking 10day
silence the passers and I was and
meditation of 12 hours a day Retreats
and all this [__] because I didn't I
I needed to find that he naturally has
equinity to some deg to a very large
degree when something really crazy bad
happens he stays centered when something
really crazy good happens yeah he has a
little celebration but he doesn't get
moved in know it's like a little buddha
and that's a skill we we work hard to
acquire he can take things and say I
have acceptance of this reality a lot
faster than most others and I think
that's a big skill yeah there's
something that that is very spiritual
and and being being not being defined by
your winds and letting them get carried
away but also not letting your losses
drown you too much either yeah it's so
hard to do though to emotionally
regulate yourself like that oh very hard
and to be honest with yourself and
honest and you think you're honest with
yourself but there's another layer of
ego slipping in and oh it's a Never
Ending Story but he's he's very he's
very good at that and I think um don't
get me wrong when he beats Tommy Fury
he's going to be he's going to he's
going to be on the walls isn't he he's
going to be on the ceiling yeah um going
back to the music side of things you
know I remember JJ's music Lamborghini
the classics which I still have a place
I'm a heart for because it's like it is
really a part of his growth in YouTube
history and seeing him go from that but
then see him go from those kind of
trucks um to Holiday which was on every
[__] radio
station were you in the studio when
these were being made and and was there
a moment where you were like oh oh we
got something here like what can you
take me back to those times where you
realized okay we're actually going
beyond the YouTube audience with this
yes yes I mean look I think again not to
take and I've want to be careful because
I'm not trying to sit here and say I'm
taking credit for everything and I've
done all these amazing things I couldn't
have done any of these amazing things
without an amazing team and without an
amazing version of JJ which he gave
himself which he gave us every day you
know um but one of it's funny you bring
holiday up the label I we sent the song
it was with Jake Gosling and digital
farm animals and we sat there and and
they sent me the song I was in LA at the
time they sent me the song and I go oh
my God this is a [__] smash this is a
smash you you got this is the next
single and JJ's like yeah but Ms you say
that about every song I'm like no no no
no this this one is is special and then
sent it to the label and God bless them
BMG were amazing with us we did a great
job but on this song they went as far as
setting up a multi uh leader Zoom call
with all the heads of Department saying
you cannot put this song out it's
[__] [__] you can't put this song out
yes you cannot do this and right think
that's as bigest hit it's as biggest hit
yeah cuz it it was everywhere it was
everywhere yeah but JJ and I we were
like we know this song is is the one you
know when you're like I can see this no
matter what anyone else tells me it
doesn't matter if if Clive Davis uh
Jimmy ivene came and said mate don't put
holiday out I would still have done it
JJ would still have done it and it
doesn't mean there weren't doubts here
and there but when we when we knew we
put it together it was like this is the
one I understand in a sense of like if
someone was to say to you this ain't
really KSI or or whatever like it ain't
his usual thing but but I mean it was a
it was a classic and that it it was very
radio friendly and anyone could listen
to it 5-year-old 50y old didn't matter
and I think that that transformed him
into a different level of artist where
even for me I'm like [__] hell he's
at Wembley Stadium singing this this is
mental like and I always thought him and
Logan were going to be big and I was
seeing that but that was that was the
magic really that you managed to pull
together to take them to that next level
well the I understood the JJ brand
fairly quickly and the JJ brand is to
keep the fans on their toes keep they
and and then his fans have a very honest
relationship with him you know and he
takes it on when it's valid and has
Merit and it's constructive criticism he
really takes it off he does yeah um they
were like oh uh he's doing all these
American features boom We did Houdini
with English features oh he needs
features for everything boom holiday so
it's all about doing the setup and then
a surprise take them away from a natural
is that why you called it all over the
place yeah well the JJ is one of the few
artists that can hop on a house song A
hip-hop track a trap song and then a pop
song like holiday there aren't many who
can get away with that's so true I think
that's cuz he's he has a unique voice
and it is it's kind of like there
there's a couple of rappers out there
who can do that but it is it is hard to
do that to just be able to transfer to
any type of music um and in terms of
like where you went from there with
Misfits you don't have a a boxing
promoter background so all of a sudden
you're put in this situation of yeah can
you help me run this boxing promotion
event what was that like well I said to
JJ I think I think and and and Liam was
managing JJ I was doing the music
management at the time of uh KSI Logan
part two and I said to Liam
I was like bro we should be doing our
own thing we should be doing this m and
you know and yeah yeah that's a great
idea blah blah blah but executing having
ideas is easy right we can all have
ideas but it's the execution and that
took a long time to put it together but
luckily I grew up with K and Nissa you
know um and you know we've known each
other from we were in brawls together
against each other's mates and like
we've got proper history you know and
then nuts by the way oh yeah so anyway I
said let's put two and two together um
and JJ was like I think it's a brilliant
idea I said look if we're going to do
music let's make sure you have your own
label Drake does this um Mayweather does
this with boxing where he has his own
promotion De La Hoya the guys who are
the wealthiest most successful let's
learn from them did a broadcast deal
with the zone for 5 years it didn't
start as a 5-year deal I think after
Misfit uh after X Series um 00
3 uh or 002 they just said no no no we
we need to lock this up and do a 5year
deal I'm not surprised when you when you
look at the other Fighters and and how
volatile the Space is having something
that's consistent is a rarity and you
guys are consistent well that's where
they went wrong the first time is there
was this massive Buzz KSI Logan 2 and
then it didn't really it took too much
time to follow up with one other card
that had I think they had Gibb and Jake
Paul after that but that was ages and
that was and that was it nothing else so
they knew and I I said this going into
the meeting I'm like but I didn't expect
that we're going to do 10 12 shows a
year I thought it's going to be like six
a year and it's just evolved you know
and um it's super fun it's super
exciting but it definitely definitely
takes up a lot of time and energy you've
got to love it Brian I used to have WWE
action figures I used to play with when
I was a kid and i' do commentary and I'd
create my own ww world yeah and I was so
UFC when that happened I was like glued
to every you know before weight classes
were a thing in the you know all of this
is an amazing kind of dream that's been
manifested and aligned with KSI like
what are the chances that we're both we
love music and we love Combat Sports or
boxing anyway um but then seeing things
like the opportunities it creates for
others other uh YouTubers other people
on the platform
um and more importantly than that the
amount of emails and texts and DMS from
moms and dads and kids saying I was
obese I was depressed um my son you've
saved his life things like this that's
that's like w we maybe we're doing
something really good here you know
maybe it's actually and I've had gym
owners tell me that they've had way more
way more memberships from uh youngsters
between 12 and 21 years old since
misfit's Inception million per there
maybe since Mike Tyson there isn't a
single uh movement in boxing that has
got as many young people interested in
boxing as this has not even close yeah I
agree yeah Anthony Joshua the lot of
them are great people but this is a
different level of impact that we're
seeing right now in terms of the thing I
love about Misfit is the the name Misfit
really sums up what you've managed to
make is unlikely Heroes right and like
people like salt papy we just looked at
him today his transformation from this
chubby kid who started off he looks like
a different human like it is insane uh
what do you make of his transformation I
think it's just the beginning as well
like this is the first time he's tried
to really cut weight you know make an
effort and now he's you know he's got
you can see his abs through his shirt j
in it I bet he didn't think that would
happen a year ago it's genuinely
inspirational like it make me go blood
yell I need to get my assing yeah yeah
and and saying um some of the
experiences that we've had on those show
like deji's first win or even um fuzy
coming out and having this moment where
you see him shredded up and the
self-improvement that it's encouraged
these guys to have my favorite actual
post fight interview was foozy and the
way he talked about you know people
wanting to feel people feeling so low
that they want to die but that's not
really how you feel it's this version of
you and he's currently going through
some stuff and I just wondered like from
someone who's worked with fuzy before
what what is does he like and and what
do you make of what we're seeing now on
the internet with all of this attention
on him and what it's sort of caused in
his mental health you know honestly
speaking I've I think we all have a
version of depression and and um you
know all these buzzword which trauma and
it again got to be very careful because
you never want to minimize anyone else's
experience something to me that caused
depression to me to another person would
be like why would that impress you that
much you know you've got a great life or
this and that and
then uh to my kid for example if if she
says I'm depressed but I don't know why
and that's that's a tough one you know
but that's very common for a lot of
people as well so everyone has a
different version of it I know fousey to
be a very pleasant fun good loving guy
um he's very intelligent but he's also
His Own Worst Enemy yeah that just feel
like like what makes everyone want to
watch him is also the thing that kind of
is destroying him it's that catastrophic
car crash TV that he puts on on his live
showes but but that's the thing you
start to become that character that
you're playing you know if you if you
play that character long enough listen
uh speaking of Hollywood um one of the
girls I dated um she was a phenomenal
actress like [__] hell amazing but
she would go and play these roles that
were really Dem ing really challenging
she was a method actor which meant she
really really immersed himself in that
like alpacino would wear a blindfold
before sent of a woman and got into the
Blind Man's character and all that she
became that person and she would become
evil this sweet amazing lovely girl
would just become absolutely pure evil
during the relationship you couldn't
separate it I think if you PR you get
good at whatever you practice if you
practice complaining a lot and being a
victim which again it happens we can all
fall into that if you practice that you
become a really good victim if you
practice taking responsibility and
saying [__] it I'm going to overcome
this that's a really masculine energy
that to to bring into something like
that and it doesn't work for everyone I
get that some people need sweetness
music whatever it is but you got to find
you got to find something that's going
to help you overcome it not make you go
deeper into it and I think the problem
with that kick deal and everything else
and kick are amazing but I'm saying um
see I've got to be a politician no but
when the money comes in it can be a lot
right yeah it can be a lot because a lot
of celebrities that we've seen from
Lindsay to Britney to Old School
celebrities you know during my
generation they weren't ready for that
level of attention and F spear are still
struggling with it now gosh yeah but
what chance does she have if you don't
and and look I've experienced that on a
much smaller scale but my circle as a
wealthy 20-some year old kid with all
these cars and all this cool stuff my
circle would just tell me hey you're
amazing even if I was [__] if I if I did
something stupid and you know
overreacted to someone hey you better
give me some [__] respect boom
something like that oh that was so funny
it wasn't funny it was [__] sad it's
CUNY of me to be that person SX taught
me that once and I was so unaware like a
girl was crossing the street and I was
like oh look at that stupid [__] with
the [__] this that I didn't mean it
it's what I grew up with and I didn't
give it any thought whatsoever and it
was just to amuse myself and say
something and amuse him he said bro
that's not funny why would you say that
years ago right and I'm like oh my God
it's not funny why the [__] would I say
that it's moments like that that he
needs to have someone around him to tell
him that if he doesn't see it himself
and not not get tempted by at the end of
the day what is Fame and money and
everything else worth if you're not
happy what is it worth because my
definition Brian of happiness and I can
say this having been broke wealthy this
that without happiness is not worth it
and it's always great to have people
like that around you uh SX there who
would give you the truth yeah and if and
you have to know like who can I trust to
tell me that and if I am acting like a
[__] I need someone to pull me up
absolutely and in terms of the The
Misfits uh roster as well as you're
bring building that up Jake Paul yet to
be on it yet to make that fight and I
know a lot of people will want to know
why and I know you kind of had to
explain this a little bit but like
there's been a lot of back and forth and
this we're in danger of this becoming
the it's oversaturated the talk about it
yeah the cliche sort of Pacquiao
Mayweather thing where when you finally
get it you're like hey Pacquiao
Mayweather still did the most
pay-per-views in history you're right
but in retrospect it does not have the
Legacy meaning fight that it once could
have had is in like for me K I's thing
is Legacy yes it is that's that's what
he's all about and to get this fight
done in time is important as well um
what went wrong you know some people
bring out the best in you and Jake's
manager on a business front brings out
the worst in me and I bring out the
worst in him and KSI and Jake bring out
the worst in each other and is that you
taking some accountability of course of
course I have to because I'm fiercely
loyal to JJ and I will always be loyal
to him you know like I'm going to try
and get him the best deal just as
they're going to try and get Jake the
best deal it was never
a he's a he's a tough guy to negotiate
with Jake's manager and not always very
fair and I try to be fair but when
someone when someone doesn't keep their
word and breaks their word with me once
then it's difficult for me to have trust
again but when he does it three times at
that point I'm like [__] you what what
what isn't fair when when him and I and
Jake's manager and I have had some
really good conversations where you
almost think I'm speaking to a mate so
it's it's such a Fickle crazy world like
that you know um one minute we're
swearing at each other we're literally
saying I'm like come on let's get in the
ring then
you we be the undercard yeah and um and
and he's saying you [__] clown you
want Clouts on through I'm like me blah
blah and we're going at it and 5 minutes
later we're like all right so let's talk
business you know what let's have a
kebab cuz we're both Iranian like let's
have a kebab at some point and we'll
we'll be okay we'll get over it it's so
funny that Jake and JJ both went for
Iranian managers I don't know what that
is yeah um watch out with Iranian
managers there's a few exceptions the
confusion for the funds is and this goes
for for the big fight in influenza
boxing and real boxing you're like if
you're two big massive names you carve
it down the middle so that the question
is how can that not be done we did
eventually we got there to point where
we're like all right look let's stop
comparing dick sizes here let's just do
50/50 you're in agreement that we're
going to do way bigger numbers if it's
in a stadium in the UK yes I am all
right me too great so that's decided
then what so we booked we actually
booked um Cardiff what is it them 90,000
[__] massive massive okay we booked
Cardiff for December 3rd I think it was
and then we discussed bringing it
forward and he rejected both dates uh
after agreeing we agreed on everything
the only two points that we didn't agree
on we agreed on weight we agreed on um
the weight was what sorry the weight was
uh 180 with a 10B rehydration okay okay
JJ is a lot smaller honestly we should
have had that with Tommy definitely yeah
but you know what the person who put his
foot down and said I don't give a [__]
make this fight happen JJ okay he said I
don't care I want this fight and I said
it's not going to happen the fury said
no uh to have him fight someone lighter
then Tommy's too big blah blah blah and
we were stuck and I was like [__] okay
we'll we'll get the Tommy in a minute
right so 180 rehydration clo1 yeah that
that was a what was agreed yes I said
look nikisa we either do 177 and a half
with no rehydration no rehydration 177
A2 or you do 180 with a 10B rehydration
that's our compromise because I can say
we want 75 JJ easily fight he could get
to 170 yes Jake can say 185 we're just
never going to make it happen so what's
a fair compromise for us and we we
agreed on that after a lot of back and
forth we agreed on the venue we agreed
on the date we agreed on pretty much
everything the only two stumbling blocks
were this one's minor the minor one was
uh basically who does the undercard and
I said one of us do the undercard as MVP
uh and one does it as Misfits uh in
terms of either we take turns in the
fights but then there was the co-main so
it was like bickering over silly things
but I said okay here's a solution you do
the co-main I'll do the rest of the card
or I'll do the co-main you do the rest
of the card either way it's cool and so
we were getting there we weren't we were
like all right we'll sort something out
cuz he wanted Amanda Serrano on the uh
com of course and I said okay then just
give me the rest so that was close to
being sorted but we both acknowledged
that's not a deal breaker then he
brought in um this thing about Winner
Takes all and I spoke to JJ and he said
yeah let's do it I said okay cool
problem is Winner Takes all is JJ's
purse Jake's purse which will be a
massive purse they put it in the middle
and The Winner Takes all but nikisa then
said no it's got to be all the promotion
stuff I'm like I've got to [__] deal
with waserman and Danone they're not
going to they're not going to say hey
let's put them money in the they're not
what what production isn't done based on
who wins is it it everyone needs paid
regard everyone needs get paid recoup
the massive money they're going to put
into this it's not like so it was
unrealistic and then even after that he
said okay we'll just do their uh their
purses me and nikisa talking personally
said okay let's do the Tommy fight and
we'll square this away we'll get it done
in December or uh or earlier they said
let's do the Tommy fight cuz they were
about to do the Tom they did the Tommy
fight at that point we were still
negotiating okay okay they did the Tommy
fight I pushed I said let's do the JJ
fight next and then he said I like
nikisa In fairness said I like this
fight I think this is what Jake should
do next I think it's a great money fight
it made a lot of sense yeah Jake said no
I don't want to do this fight and his
excuse was I want to redeem my loss by
fighting a bigger name uh which let's
face it as big a name as Nate is he's
not as tough a challenge as JJ would be
yeah it that fight yeah it the event
wasn't what I think they hoped it would
have become and I think part of that St
Nate just didn't really put his foot
down and really give it 100% he was
there to cash the check yeah and uh I
suppose that's you know better the devil
you know they should have done it with
JJ I think in that in that regard uh do
you think that this can still happen and
do you think after the Tommy fight we
will see it regardless of the Tommy
result or do you think it's still going
to be problematic I hope that it does
happen I think fans deserve it I would
love to make it happen I would love the
negotiation to be live
streamed I would love it to be live
streamed everyone out in the open say
what you want anything hidden any
[__] and not go in there with oh let
me have these points so I can make you
look bad and you can make me look bad
that's why it won't happen if we do that
but if we go in sincerely with an
intention of making this fight happen
then I think it should I think you know
I said they bring the worst out in each
other I think they also bring the best
out in each other oh yeah imagine if
Jake bought Kingpin and he was like this
is my company now it would be amazing
for fits boxing too they that's what you
need you need competition to drive you
even further to push you to your limit
Kingpin seems to have been run in a
crazy way what was it like for you on as
a as a not as a competitor but as as
someone in the space watching that all
unfold the way it did cuz you must have
had an idea cuz even I had an idea I was
watching the production that they were
putting on and I know how much
production cost and you know how they
they're paying a lot of money for
Fighters like um Gibb for example who I
was so happy for G but you do Wonder
like what's the pay-per-view Buy rate
going to be like to justify all of this
it's a tough tough space with the
pirating very tough and even without the
pirating when you're overpaying to that
degree I think they learned from their
mistakes they're really nice guys from
my experience and my dealings with them
um and they they ran into some
unfortunate problems so look you've got
to study do you remember Affliction had
a had an organization I remember when
they had they were buying every paying
everybody lots history repeats itself so
for me it's like I said to King Kenny to
Jay swingler to zenetti to all these
guys to L I said you guys I can't I even
said it to slim at the time and salt
papy as well I said you guys I can't
compete with this fee because it's not
worth it you're getting overpaid so go
and get overpaid go and do it God bless
you I I don't want to hold you back and
be you know like uh be some controlling
guy when you've got an opportunity to
make double what I can offer you or you
know even more so in some cases go make
your money and come back ironically they
went and they didn't make that money cuz
they half of them didn't seem to even
get paid and the saddest bit from what
I've been told is they didn't even get
replied to they they just got blanked as
if they didn't even exist and then then
you've got that girl who showed AB boobs
and was told oh you can do that get your
boobs out just don't say it was from me
and then he sucks her after everyone's
in uproar about it so the the
reputational damage that's been done by
Kingpin is horrendous I'll say this
without saying too much it's really not
all their fault I don't want to just be
uh flapping my mouth about it's not all
their fault there's circumstances and
things that happened that that were very
very tough on them as well and I'm not
I'm sure look they've made their
mistakes everyone made
mistake but yeah it's it's never it's
never just one-sided fully oh yeah um
I'm I'm sure they had it hard but when
you owe people money and you're not even
acknowledging their existence that's
never good no no no no and yeah I don't
think they should be allowed to promote
a show again for that reason to me like
if you haven't paid Fighters you're done
in my opinion yeah no I can't I can't
argue with that I mean that's the one
thing I think that no one can even
haters of misfitz boxing can say is like
everyone gets paid and if if there's a
delay on payment it's usually cuz they
send the wrong bank account you know so
moving on to the prime card this is to
me the the graduation of what you've
been building you've been learning a lot
you've had so many crazy moments from
that Nazi guy like so like what was that
like by the way oh that was that was
what I was saying those two three days
for me well [__]
hell for those who don't know by the way
KSI had like opponent pull out he tried
to put someone in with him turned out
he's a [__] lunatic who looked like
he'd escaped from prison or whatever um
and yeah we found out he was a bloody
Nazi or something um but yeah now now
here's the interesting thing my my main
surprise when we were talking in the
WhatsApp group when we were trying to
fill the Cod and say who should fight
who Dylan danis you were unanimously
outvoted that we shouldn't you know we
were saying we don't believe he's going
to show up so don't give him the chance
but you spoke to him and you said look
I've talked to him and I believe he's
going to show up what is it about Dylan
that convinced you I think he has a
hunger inside him and he's got he's got
to overcome these demons as well and I
think that's where he's going to do it
in the ring I mean can I ask you what
the hunger is for do you remember I was
telling you I got in the music music
business because I wanted to be
famous I agree and and it's not who I am
today in any way shape or form but at
the same time maybe he finds himself
through this journey I don't know what
his journey is but at the end of the day
it's been a tough ride Logan chose uh
said I want to I've had a beef with this
guy let me fight him I want to fight him
as well so ultimately it was up to Logan
who he decided to fight but I will give
Logan a lot of credit that when I when
we put the options before him of about a
replacement opponent he went straight
for Mike Perry who is a bare knuckle
Legend at this point he's a tough tough
gu yeah it ain't an easy fight that no
cuz we were like Yeshua like our
response in the group chat was like that
and Logan seemed very confident against
him as well right oh yeah incredibly
like there's no doubt he's like you you
don't know you don't know I'm like bro
you sure that's a tough tough guy so you
make the Dyan Dan fight despite him
pulling out last time which must have
been a nightmare was a nightmare yeah
and with 10 days to spare and after
everyone told you he was probably going
to pull out is there not severe worries
this time or what like what level of
contract are we talking about where
you're saying you're going to find him
100 Grand to to to make sure that that
happens well here's the thing I think
he's got way more to lose if he does it
twice in a row I don't think anyone will
work with him I don't think any promoter
worth a dam will ever ever work with him
if he if he pulled out um and as the
fight is nearing I I really have more
confidence than ever before that he's
going to fight I mean he's built this
now he's the anti-hero guy he's built
this image he's got this popularity he's
where he wanted to be and he's loved for
it yeah you know yeah he definitely is
you can't deny that so if he doesn't
show up he undo all of that work and is
left with a lawsuit and nothing to show
for it and minus 100 Grand potentially
yeah so what did you and and the guys at
Misfit and desor these tweets are coming
out from Dylan he's going after Logan's
uh wife to be what what's your thoughts
and feelings on all of that cuz you're
you're essentially the the guy who's
creating the situation and you probably
didn't think he was going to do this of
course not I had no clue I would look at
the end of the day as a dad to a
daughter I I you know I don't I don't
condone what he's done Logan is a good
friend but it's also undeniable that
he's gotten a lot of attention for it
and brought it to the fight and how do
you think he's handling the Dylan
situation um when he talks about it to
you is he I think I know you've checked
in with him right I have but he doesn't
he doesn't say oh man I'm going through
a lot of [__] with this it's terrible he
just stays stoic and strong so I don't
know you know behind closed doors what's
going on but he certainly seems
enthusiastic in our group chats very
friendly and on top of things he never
misses a you know opportunity to make a
joke and and make a uh intelligent
suggestion about marketing strategies
for Prime and this and that so I don't
know to him to him he's uh to us he's
not shown anything these two because of
the level of hatred that you can see
building this event because of that is
going to be through the roof cuz you've
got such value there Eddie hear must be
so jealous of you right now because this
is going to be one of the biggest events
in UK sport history I think so you know
we got these Brazilians we got the
furies Bringing In traditional boxing
enthusiasts we got um MMA community and
I even saw Cedric jaes and Testo
commenting on Dylan I'm definitely
watching this I don't think they've seen
one yeah and because Dylan is a villain
in the MMA space like the MMA guys a lot
of them have disliked him they want to
see him get beat yeah so there's a whole
group of people who want to see Logan
get beat whole group of people want to
see Dylan get be people want to see KSI
get beat people want to see Tommy get
beat it's the perfect storm for that
reason I wanted to showcase the best of
what we have so we might not get a you
know you get one chance to make a first
impression and I want it to be a good I
credit you and you know at first there
was a lot of questions about who is this
mom's guy and you know and what is
Misfit becoming but this is a real
moment of like like UFC 100 or
WrestleMania I suppose you want to do
one of these a year right so it's going
to be an epic moment that you can build
around and and look the main event Tommy
Fury KSI talked to me about the
negotiations for that you'd have thought
Tommy being the fighting man would have
been easy to negotiate with was he I'll
tell you what it wasn't easy but it was
easy in comparison to negotiations with
Jake for example wow okay really really
was because who were you negotiating
with was it Big John actually no yes uh
K was K was negotiating with Big John
and everything went through Big John
nothing love that big John at least it
wasn't such a back and forth and um it
wasn't you know they said at one point
they're like look this is
it either you take it or leave it
Tommy's not and they were serious like
Tommy's not going Jake was waiting in
the wings for his rematch I guess Jake
didn't want his rematch right away you
know and that's what we thought he was
going to go for but he didn't want his
rematch which then we said okay then
you've got to fight KSI who else is
there no one and then yeah that's The
Narrative of the ducking and the this
look and I'll go back to Tommy and the
prime card in a sec but I think that
Jake where does he go after he loses to
KSI let's say hypothetically for people
who think Jake will 100% win I think K
KSI is going to 100% win but let's just
imagine Jake loses to KSI what happens
cuz that's what he's that's all he's got
unless it's a massively close
fight that's that Demands a rematch
right where does he go from a lost to
KSI this guy who wants to fight Canelo
and become the world champion of uh the
WBC and WBO one day he lost to KSI and
he lost to Tommy Fury then what you know
so it's a risky risky move for him
that's truly what I think has made it
sour but listen I'm going to be biased
I'm going to be on KSI side maybe
there's something I'm missing but from
my perspective assessing this I'm like I
get why Jake was hesitant cuz I thought
he would have jumped at it he was
jumping at it when Wasabi backed out he
said all right let's do it he was riding
away of that and I think I don't know if
the loss has made him think twice or I
don't know and JJ also look as much as
JJ was like bro let's do this I said no
you you know his train said no not yet
yeah it's not two weeks no we've been
training for Wasabi we haven't been
training for Jake Paul it was a lot
riskier for JJ to fight Jake then he had
a much higher chance of losing at that
point and now yeah JJ was so green he
still hadn't had he's had a lot more
fight since then he's had a lot more
training sparring SP my worry for the
Tommy Fury fight is the incremental
jumps have been um reasonable but the
jump between Joe fory and Tommy f Fury
is for me a massive jump whereas if you
look at Jake Paul's jump from Anderson
Silva to Tommy Fury and Tyron Woodley it
doesn't feel to me as big of a jump and
I I'd seen Jake in eight rounders and
he'd been through it and I thought you
know what even if it's not going his way
he's got enough to keep himself in the
fight and and see the fight out yeah
whereas with KSI it's kind of a
beautiful unknown moment where I'm like
I I know you can punch I [__] know
you can punch but I don't know what
other than that there's so cuz he's been
knocking people out so quickly we
haven't seen him in the in the trenches
and we haven't seen him against like a
big guy like Anderson Silva where you
know you're having to took took in and
and make sure you see the round out so
are you a little bit worried that maybe
this has come a little too quick or no
worries because we were unable to
execute the trajectory of opponents in
the way that we initially wanted to um I
think for that reason he's
almost under a lot of pressure to or I
think that the decision was partly
because he had to there's a couple of
things he wanted Jake he really wanted
to fight Jake when Jake's not available
what's the best option actually even a
better option than fighting Jake is to
fight the guy who beat Jake that's how
you make a statement um with with that
and I think because he didn't fight uh
UFC Legends or anything like that I
think it's necessary for him to have to
make this jump to prove his point CU he
always says I'm better than Jake I'll
beat the [__] out of Jake I believe it
his team believes it m so why not go for
it and and it's unfortunate the build
couldn't have been a little bit more um
strategically kind of um I guess
appropriate for you know or or or more
more sensical in terms of the build you
know going from this guy who's this
level this guy and it is is what it is
but he really wanted this fight after
Jake said no and I think if I believe JJ
wins this I really do and I believed it
with Logan and I'll tell you the level
of confidence was he was shooting a
music video with Rick Ross and little
baby and SX uh the day after the fight
with Logan and BMG were like but what if
he loses what do we do we spent all this
money on the set we've got all these
guys flights and their entourages and
everyone in LA to do this video what if
he loses and I just said he's not he's
not losing don't worry he'll be there
you know because I believe in him
because he believes in himself yeah if
JJ had a doubt I'd [__]
myself but but he doesn't and I see him
and I'm like if
JJ was to beat Tommy Fury and I'm not I
I think he beats him eight out of 10
times but if he was to beat him one out
of 10 times that one time will be
October 14th it's so funny cuz I did my
face off reaction a couple of days ago
and I said the one thing I'm 100% sure
of is whatever the best version of JJ is
he will be there on that day because he
is the the man in the arena like he's so
good at being calm and present in a
moment where everyone else is feeling
the [__] nerves he shows up yeah ab
and he is a big game player and the the
and that's why he beat Logan in my
opinion because he had more of that than
Logan did at that moment and um and as
much I think Tommy is a better boxer
than KSI is in terms of technique I
Tommy like for all he was like big John
was saying if we don't finish Jake Paul
that's a loss for us well you didn't you
didn't even come close to it because the
nerves man they [__] people don't
understand he went from the curtain
jerker at Wembley for his big brother
where no one even gave a [__] to being
the main event in Saudi Arabia that
atmosphere ain't going to compare it to
Manchester and you really have to have
your balls together in that moment I
guess when you're walking out you're
right you're right and I I you know I
hope that is the case on that night
where that plays a big part but at the
end of the day he has experienced it on
a big stage once before second time will
it be the same will it be easier he
might he may be better for it yeah JJ
can't rely on any of those factors we
can hope for them but what JJ's
preparing for is plan a plan B plan C
Plan D have you seen him sparring yes
and how are you feeling compared to
previous versions of JJ what what what
are you feeling like if obviously you
honor the code of not revealing who he
sparred and how things happen so I I
won't go there but he's put down some
boys that he shouldn't be putting down
that are tougher than Tommy as boxers MH
and if he shows up as that guy that I've
seen sparring which he's better on Fight
Night than he is there's a lot of gym
fighters who are amazing at sparring
absolutely and [__] uh when it comes to
under the lights and vice versa it's
funny cuz Tommy said that he went if it
was all about sparring I'd be a world
champion yeah well then true maybe maybe
you're better in the gym bro maybe he is
yeah um but yeah listen at the end of
the day I think I think for us Prime
card um it can't get bigger than this
the stakes are so high he is massively
the underdog yeah really really the
underdog that's the story of the Prime
card the other story of the Prime card
is there's a there's been a absolute
hatred built up between Lan Paul and
Dylan danis Logan wants to ring his neck
do you think there'll be any handshake
afterwards I can't see it I can't either
and you know what Logan is that guy
normally like he does yeah do you
remember with JJ he told me before the
fight even if I
win like I'm going to shake his hand and
it'll be all good like I I'm ready to
let this go now do you know what I mean
and uh but I don't see that happening if
anything he I think this is going to be
I don't even think this is over after
the fight you know I think it might even
just have begun like we might cuz the
lawsuit and [__] you know the MMA fight
if they have one yeah if they W yeah
what about would KSI and Jake shake each
other's hand after their fight I think
they mate you think so yeah cuz there's
respect there why why would you care
about beating the guy so badly if you
didn't respect them it wouldn't mean
anything clearly respect each other it
gives them both a purpose I think JJ
admitted that um for for a long time he
just he got to a point where he gave up
on it you know and he said okay let me
do the next best thing for me you know
uh you mentioned what should Jake do and
I've been thinking about this cuz
genuinely like after that Nate Diaz
fight I I just felt a little bit like
they saying going in the direction that
you're you're talking about right now
you know you're you're You're Going the
Distance with Nate Diaz well done good
result who would have thought you'd have
beaten a years ago not many credit to
you but equally you're not looking like
a world champion boxer and I know that
that's going to take time if you want to
do that but personally if I was Jake I'd
be thinking about MMA um you se you can
put MMA guys down learn the rest of it
and uh you know MMA is different you can
you can make your way up the ranks
differently than than a box boxing it's
a lot more down to your skill set and
just you know there's so many different
dimensions in MMA if you're great at one
thing and you fill in the gaps and the
rest you can you can do stuff totally
yeah yeah and I think I think Logan
would be great at MMA as well he's a
great wrestler got he's got the Bas his
strength is you know you could argue
Logan might be better at MMA than than
any of these guys just in terms of the
athlete he is it's a joke yeah he's an I
mean WWE who does that in such a short
time I'll never forget this dude [__]
the viral moment where he's like doing
that on the turnbuckle and then before
you know KS I on the thing getting I was
so [__] it that day I'm like there
in the front is he okay is have they
rehearsed that much or was that the
first time they did it or am I allowed
to say I don't know assume that they you
can say it well didn't want to do it too
much because because you know it's a
bloody risky thing and it hurts but he
was okay and we made sure he was okay
thank God and then he was fighting
forier a couple of weeks after I'll
never forget that moment where KSI peels
the mask off and his eyes are there he's
like the funniest [__] I've ever seen
classic one of the biggest moments this
year has got to have been Connor
McGregor calling out KSI your eyes must
been ching ching ching ching ching you
must have been thinking the money's
coming in here like what do you make of
that whole situation you know honestly
again I swear I'm not it's not the money
it's more like Conor McGregor the legacy
of Conor McGregor KSI and uh you know
the potential of that happening
obviously uh Prime UFC all of that the
relationships I I mean yeah you you guys
are sponsoring the UFC so I I think it's
all doable and I think I fighter is
doable yeah and I think I think it's
something that would make a lot of sense
in terms of Legacy I
mean KSI versus Conor McGregor massive
massive massive fight just even saying
that sentence you're like dude I I mean
so many of my videos have been about
both of these guys and i' I've you know
thanks to the both of them I owe them a
fair bit of money 20% but um even if
Conor haters I I respect that but that
fight would just be the ultimate in
terms of clicks wouldn't it it would be
insane I think we'll see a lot more of
Connor uh around Misfits and you know
with Uncle Dana's blessing hopefully
everything you know uh we could we could
hopefully see that in the future yeah I
mean he is looking like he's coming to
the end of his MMA career but the the
hunger to be in a ring or a combat sport
situation is just there with him it'll
probably not leave him and if he can
with his with his leg not being 100% it
probably never will be after that to do
boxing makes sense and he's he's already
done it before with Mayweather why not
make extra money you know with these
YouTube guys I mean and especially KSI
because the size of KSI and Connor is
not that far apart at all all and and
let's not forget like Connor has hands
Conor actually like when he fought Aldo
didn't everyone like do do you remember
how you felt when you saw that it was a
a once in a lifetime moment mate that
was like this guy is capable of magic he
called this first round knockout yeah
died never lost in 10 years and boom out
called first punch it was mental amazing
yeah yeah and it it it it is a shame
where he's at right now in terms of
like I guess for me him calling out KSI
was a sign of the times as well like is
this you like you you you're normally
the guy calling out the world champions
but but everyone has has their day and
and I think that that's a way of him
extend his legacy and and fighting and
and to keep the show going and to keep
himself occupied yeah and it it's got to
be you know like I think he has fun
doing it he has fun on the microphone
being on stage and all of that that's
what it's about I mean um will will his
legacy I think his
legacy will always be there for what it
is but obviously if it went a different
way and uh he kept that hunger in the
UFC and didn't maybe um stayed more
disciplined that's the tough part with
partying and and enjoying the success
for a bit too long it takes away the
hunger and I suppose that's a trap that
that you kind of want to steer KSI away
from and and weirdly for as long as I've
known him it's that's never been an
issue for him it it happened for a very
brief period of time oh really what was
that like
um that was that was basically what
happened
was he went
[Music]
through okay so during lockdown is he's
been famous for a long time right in the
different he was internet famous YouTube
famous like all of that people would
recognize him when we first started we'd
walk out maybe three people would come
up to him over a duration of 30 minutes
like hey what's up oh your KSI your KSI
or four people five people but it wasn't
what it became during lockdown and he
didn't know cuz he was locked down and
then suddenly the music the interviews
Jonathan Ross and this and that and the
other all the household name then right
household name the goggle box all of it
it was and the ratings were all crazy
for all of these shows they were spiking
as soon as KSI was on there so he
suddenly would go out and I remember it
happened we went to watch an England
match
and everyone like we had you know he had
security and everything else but
everyone was coming to mob him and after
that he's always had security with him
since that day it was genuin we've seen
the big dude yeah yeah and and Steve was
with him for a long time before that
Steve but now it's like we took measures
because it felt unsafe wherever he went
so those days where it was four or five
people coming up to him randomly if word
gets out people mob him and it got to
that state and then suddenly he was in a
place where I think he was getting a lot
more attention from you know oh yeah
took him only a matter of months to say
hey this isn't me how did you notice it
though from the outside was there a
moment where you were like dude what the
[__] we'd speak about it we talk about
it a lot and he's like yeah I want to I
want to experience this I want to
experience that and I just said all
right well look if this is what you want
if you don't experience what you're
itching to experience then you'll always
wonder we always wonder yeah so if
that's how you feel go do it and then he
was like [__] bro I [__] up I didn't I
don't want to do this and he didn't [__]
up in any way who was really honest
throughout the whole thing um and you
know that was I'm just picturing like 10
women in him in a room or
something
listen you picture it but but um at the
end of the day I was so impressed with
that cuz if that was me I'd be Rock
starring it for five 10 years 15 years I
might not come back you know now I would
now I'm grounded but at that age with
with the circumstan as being what they
were I was like [__] hell that's a
strong guy to be able to see that and
say hey this doesn't make me happy this
is an illusion this is what makes me
happy and now I know that isn't it funny
right how we see the the ego version of
him when he's on camera and he's like
Tommy Fury and it's [__] hilarious
right but but people people will react
to that on Twitter and be like this guy
you know what I mean and the real truth
of the matter is is like if every one of
those people out there
were given all of the things that he has
been given in life would you be able to
keep yourself as grounded off camera as
what he does it's it's challenging like
100% he's done a better job of it than I
would have done for real like seriously
I think I'd be dead yeah but but you
know he um yeah if you're if you're in a
room with him at at some elegant party
or something like that an awards
ceremony that guy is an introvert 100%
he's an introverted guy it's not easy
unless you know him to make conversation
with him in those circumstances because
he's not that comfortable going out and
being around loads of people he likes to
be around his familiar circumstances
there's a switch that he flicts I feel
like where he becomes cha yeah and
there's like JJ who's the l l like more
ly chill like really chill guy super
chill yeah complete opposite version of
that that brings us to the final
question I guess is um how would you
like to be remembered you know I used to
really think that was important I used
to think it was so important but I don't
think it's important as long as my
daughter thinks of me as someone who was
very present and influential and did
everything could to love her to a small
circle of people I'll Be Remembered in
fleeting moments oh yeah he's a nice guy
oh yeah do you remember when he did this
what
wanker but guess what I won't be around
to see it or hear it or read the tweets
so and I really appreciate the chat mate
this has been fantastic we've definitely
got some gold out of view today so
thanks very much thanks for having me I
really appreciate it a nice one uh don't
forget you can check out the prime card
on Dione uh which will be coming up uh
in October what's the date again October
14th Prime card baby yeah we'll be
checking that out big love to moms and
everyone up Misfits and
[Music]
peace
oh